we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting voicemail i recieved take a
listen hello david this is travis from
california i was just calling to get
your opinion on what what happens next
if Moeller actually brings charges
against trump if he shows the evidence
that trump is guilty of something and no
one acts what happens next
nothing what precedent is that going
forward yep well this is uh thank you
but thank you this is something i've
been talking about which is that at this
point
Moeller has been sufficiently smeared to
the point that if you don't have a
republican i'm sorry a Democratic House
and Senate as a result of the November
2018 election probably nothing happens
to Trump and we already have
increasingly confirmed from a legal
perspective that you can't indict a
sitting president meaning that in order
to really get charges to have
consequences against Trump you would
need the first impeach him Republicans
have made it pretty clear they're just
not going to impeach if there's no
political appetite for that yeah and the
Republicans smear tactics against Robert
Miller are working I guess the the
investigation is not as popular as it
once was right it's almost 50/50 when it
comes to popularity yeah so the answer
is unless you vote in November and get
Democrats elected to the House and
Senate to the point that Democrats take
control nothing is going to happen and
more than likely even the people some of
the people who have been indicted or or
maybe indicted are just going to get
pardoned and I wish that it was
something else but if anything this
should be even more motivation to
actually get out there and vote in
November on today's bonus show what a
bonus show we have today we will talk
about the willingness of American
workers to quit their jobs has hit a
17-year high is this as simple as when
the economy is good and there's low
unemployment people feel confident that
they could quickly find another job
even though that is actually
counterintuitive when there are fewer
unemployed people that also often means
that there aren't necessarily that many
available jobs because most people are
working so we'll talk about that a
little bit we will also talk about a new
study which shows that virtual reality
turns out
pretty effective at curing some
real-life fears including the fear of
heights and we will also talk about a
move in Alabama to limit sheriff's from
pocketing jail food money seems like
something you want to prevent sheriff's
from doing right yeah we've got ever
allowed in the first place that is a
really good question and we will discuss
whether it is a problem just in Alabama
or whether Alabama is sort of ahead of
the curve in curbing a problem that
exists all over the country two ways to
access the bonus show become a member at
WWJ pakman.com or become a patron at
double at patreon.com forward slash
david pakman show